avec brahim ould mansour spécialiste du
maghreb et chercheur associé à l'iris
l'institut des relations internationales
et stratégiques
bonjour en braille moment de sourds
merci de répondre à nos questions selon
les autres choses vote sur la révision
de la constitution vise donc à répondre
aux aspirations du mouvement de
protestation du irak poudre aux yeux
comme le disent des opposants ou
véritable volonté politique de
changement
oui il ya une volonté bien sûr d'eux
pour le présidente e bonne deux à la
fois doux d'utiliser ce référendum pour
la constitution de honteux bien sûr de
dodo de se doter d'une légitimité
populaire compte tenu du temps très bas
2 2 la participation aux élections
président présidentielle de 2012
un choix aussi un choix de la date de la
date d'aujourd'hui le 1er novembre
anniversaire de la guerre du
déclenchement de la guerre
d'indépendance dans le choix symbolique
mais également pour soutenir la décision
assez à ce projet ont de la révision
constitutionnelle
par contre il est difficile aujourd'hui
d'imaginer que qu'il y ait un engouement
un engouement populaire
un entretien ce populaire aura des voté
pour multiples raisons bien sûr ça
s'inscrit cette seule référendum
s'inscrit dont le vent de contestation
bien dans le contexte du vent de
contestation marquée par le vent de
contestation au pardon qui qui dure
maintenant depuis plusieurs mois qui
revendique avec le hacker qui revendique
un changement profond un changement
politique profond avec de nouvelles
élites politiques
il ya aussi la fragilité économique très
inquiétante du pays
aggravée à la fois par par des années de
corruption effrénée mais aussi la crise
sanitaire de lakovic 19 qui ont obligé
l'état de diviser par deux le budget
annuel
aussi la situation on a sauté du
président qui l'obligera qui l'obligent
à cette version
quid de sa légitimité par rapport à ce
référendum est ce que ça peut avoir une
incidence une conséquence exactement
bien sûr ça va encore une fois renforcé
le clan j'étais sceptique vis-à-vis
vis-à-vis de la de la hd réel ou la
santé du pouvoir globalement ce qu'ils
revendaient qu'un changement vont dire
voilà nikaïa il ya une sorte de route de
deuil en soit il ya une sorte de deux
mondes et rage cette image d'un prisé
dans malades qu'ils se soient longues
l'un la période électorale on a vu ça
l'année dernière avec le président
potash les cas aucun ça risque de deux
aujourd'hui encore une fois de renforcer
le clan du boycott mais il faut aussi
ajouter justement cet appel au boycott
massif est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à ce
que le wi lan porte puisque de nombreux
opposants ne vont pas aller voter
il a peut-être non parce que cette fois
ci il ya plusieurs parties plus sur les
forces amies mais aussi concerts au sein
des conservateurs qui voyaient dans
cette constitution une atteinte à
l'identité islamique du pays
considérons cette constitution consacre
la laïcité à l'école notamment donc
des partis islamistes comme le msp qui
demande d'être simplement de voter mais
de voter non donc il ya à la fois il ya
la fois un front au boycott mais
également un franc de reçus par le
ventre bien sûr en vente maintenant et
qui risquent de encore une fois terminée
7,7 ce projet du président actuel
finalement est-ce que le véritable enjeu
de ce référendum ce n'est pas le taux de
participation
oui c'est tout à fait c'est tout à fait
ça le présidente e boucle aujourd'hui où
le pouvoir globalement veut texan se
racheter un digitimes était populaire
rapidement le ton très bas
historiquement le plus bas lors des
élections présidentielles passées ce qui
ce qui même aujourd'hui
ce qui fit de ce référendum est sans
peau de test de popularité en tout cas
du président appelait match de telles
bonnes mais c'est en quelque sorte il ya
il ya une une à une
aujourd'hui on sent quand même la
contestation reste très très forte de la
part de plusieurs partis politiques
d'opposition mais aussi de des partis
qui avaient jusque-là promu une position
médiane
merci brahim en dessous d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes spécialiste du maghreb de l'afrique
du nord et chercheur à l'iris l'institut
des relations internationales et
stratégiques